if you want to be the most efficient
zombie killing machine in Call of Duty
World War two you're gonna want the
Tesla gun Call of Duty World War two
brings back the iconic zombies mode but
not without a few changes of its own
apart from the more in-depth class
system and abilities you are now given
more apparent objectives as display
there are no objective markers but if
you press the touchpad a small to-do
list appears in the corner of the screen
and certain points of interest will be
highlighted if you're in the vicinity of
course as with every zombie map you can
totally ignore the objectives and just
kill zombies but if you want to get to
test the gun here's what you'll need to
do step 1 gas that generator once you've
opened the first door you'll want to
activate these three valves if you go to
the generator near the bunker entrance
you can follow the hoses to the valves
be careful though it takes a while to
juice up the generator so make sure
there's some distance between you and
the zombies before you start step 2
clear the sewers after you've hit all
three valves head to the center of town
again and activate the pilot lights
dig in because right after you blow a
hole in the sewers special fast-moving
zombies will crawl out and attack you
once you've cleansed the sewers of those
smelly zombies you can flick on the
generator
no problem step three reroute the power
once you enter the bunker hit the Box a
few times rack up some points and turn
this crank if you forget to turn this
crank in the early rounds you're gonna
have a bad time
once you're feeling good about your
equipment open the door to the lab and
to the morgue you'll need a hit a switch
like this on both sides within a limited
amount of time if you have more than two
people it's a good idea to coordinate
and hit the switches together step 4
transfer device now we're gonna head
into the salt mine and activate the guys
craft transfer device basically you flip
the switch and kill zombies in the red
circle after it lights up orange head
back upstairs
step 5 collect the parts once you're
back upstairs head to the far end of the
room go up the stairs and hit the button
the guyst craft transfer device will
either head to the lab or the more for
us it went to the lab first follow it
and continue to kill zombies within the
circle once it reaches the end and the
machine is done doing whatever it's
doing grab the part and head back to the
center now you're gonna have to do the
same thing on the other side step 6
build the Tesla gun return to the centre
of the bunker and assemble the Tesla gun
don't worry everyone in your squad will
get one of these fancy killing machines
there is still much more to this zombie
map that we are still figuring out let
us know if you'd like to see more in the
future and thank you for watching
[Music]